au moment de découvrir la salle Stéphane
Plaza ne cache pas son appréhension
et ben voilà là je peux vous dire que je
l'ai
en Chine une entreprise a troqué son PDG
en chair et en os contre une
intelligence artificielle aux États-Unis
c'est un concours artistique qui a été
remporté par une intelligence
artificielle
alors ces outils sont-ils fiables
l'homme risque-t-il d'être dépassé par
les créatures qu'il a lui-même créé
pas mal pas mal on y croit
[Musique]
voici le nouveau quotidien des hôpitaux
chinois qui croule sous la vue des
passions covid un temps épargné les
soignants peignent désormais à prendre
en charge tous les malades certains
hôpitaux n'ont même plus assez de lit
pour tout le monde les chiffres
officiels minimisent la mortalité par
exemple seulement si des séances à Pékin
lors des 15 derniers jours mais devant
les crématoriums les balais des
corbillards se font de plus en plus
fréquents
[Applaudissements]
le virus circule désormais plus
activement et le pays connaît une vague
d'ampleur sans précédent même les
médicaments contre la fièvre viennent à
manquer la situation étant plus aggravée
par un faible taux de vaccination
seulement 40% des plus de 80 ans ont
reçu leur dose de rappel ceci inquiète
fortement l'OMS un de mes enjeux majeurs
c'est dans les années qui viennent
transformer un peu notre société vers
une société de plus de prévention et la
prévention ça ne se décrète pas
par des circonstances exceptionnelles
bien entendu mais par exemple quand on
parle du port du préservatif qu'on va
rendre là le président a annoncé gratuit
le port du préservatif on va pas faire
un décret pour dire il faut porter une
préservatif ça fait partie de la
prévention je bois du couscous et je
nettoie un paysan
[Musique]
le préservatif gratuit je trouve que
c'est vraiment infantilisé mais non mais
sexualité c'est la conquête de
l'autonomie c'est vraiment pousser
l'assistana un peu loin quand même
franchement il y a tellement de choses
qui parfois peuvent me déranger que ça
pour le coups
vertigineuse et dangereuse ces deux
femmes qui nettoient des vitres dans une
ville du nord-est de la Chine ont été vu
des millions de fois sur les réseaux
sociaux la vidéo diffusée par un voisin
les montres en équilibre sur le rebord
des fenêtres au 11e étage d'un immeuble
sans harnais de sécurité si certains
internautes ironisent sur le fait
qu'elle soit bien protégées car elle
porte un masque d'autres s'offusent que
des conditions de travail au détriment
d'une vie c'est la société américaine
Mattel qui édite le jeu qui a décidé de
retirer plusieurs dizaines de mots de la
liste officielle du Scrabble des mois
caractères racistes et homophobes mais
en pratique comment faire pour que les
joueurs
les utilise plus peut-être pour les
compétitions officielles effectivement
mettre un cadre éviter que ça aille les
débordements que ça puisse approcher
soit bon
c'est discriminant c'est racistes faire
l'abandon
ce sens-là
je me souviens pas l'avoir utilisé quand
on a un Z de toute façon on essaie de le
placer au mieux pour faire le top des
points c'est Elisabeth borne a reçu un
maillot de l'équipe de France de foot
deux jours après la finale perdu face à
l'Argentine lors de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar ça c'est sympa c'était le repas de
Noël le gouvernement enfin voilà ils
sont réunis avec les minions
dans une entreprise bon c'est une bonne
idée en maillot de l'équipe de France
sauf que celui-là avait une
particularité il y a un flocage une
inscription 49 à l'avant et 3 dans le
dos regardez la carte Clément Beaune le
ministre des Transports très occupé avec
les grèves à une petite déconvenue il
doit aller à Arles mais comme des
centaines de milliers de Français et
bien son train a été annulé ça ne
s'invente pas pour Bruno Le Maire ce
sera comme à son habitude quelques jours
au Pays Basque Marlène Schiappa elle
sera en famille au Mans quand à
Elisabeth borne les vacances seront très
courtes seulement deux jours dans
l'Ouest et après je dirais moi il y a
les deux petites cerises sur le gâteau
ça s'il l'est pas c'est pas grave mais
s'il y a les pieds c'est un crack en
informatique et un bon cuisinier bon en
informatique ah ouais ah ouais mais
parce que vous avez toujours un truc qui
tombe en panne n'est-ce pas
je me dis le bon parti pour moi c'est
Jacky
par exemple 47% des amateurs de barbecue
estiment qu'il y a pas des courgettes
barbecues de la viande barbecue estime
qu'il est normal qu'une femme s'occupe
des tâches domestiques contre 21% en
population générale de même 41% des
personnes mangeant de la viande chaque
jour estime que le travail d'une femme
c'est de s'occuper de la maison et de la
famille si vous voulez embrasser avant
de partir alors justement
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
ma petite fiancée Marie que j'aime vous
savez pas si bien dire parce qu'il y en
avait plus dans ma loge en fait
je vous dis la vérité il y en avait plus
dans ma loge du vrai voilà et ils m'ont
mis vous savez les espèces de gros gros
papier toilettes horrible vous avez des
trucs des entreprises qui vous rappelez
fait voilà merci pour ce cadeau de Noël
Joseph